لغه استطلاعات الراي والترشيحات تضع ترامب
على راس البيت الابيض سنه 2024 تقرير مطول
لمجله ذا ايكونوميستوقع نجاح ترامب في
العوده الى رئاسه الولايات المتحده من
جديد المجله وبعد قراءه متانيه لحظوظ
الاسماء المترشحه لحد الان خلصت الى ان
الكلمه الاخيره في الانتخابات القادمه
ستكون للرئيس الجمهوري السابق
ترامب استفاد جيدا من دروس الماضي وهو
منعكس جليا على حملته الانتخابيه الجاريه
والتي بدات عمليا منذ خسرته الانتخابات
الماضيه تقول المجله وتبدو كيف ترامب ارجح
داخل الحزب الجمهوري بعدما بات يتحكم في
دواليبه بشكل جيد من خلال سحب البساط من
تحت اقدام خصومه الذين اصبحوا قله قليله
وعلى شكان اسم تراب هو اكثر اسم جمهوري
تداولا خلال العقد الاخير ورغم بزوغي شمس
بعض الاسماء مثل حاكم ولايه فلوريدا روند
سانتس الا انها بعيده عن منافسه فحسب
استطلاع لراي اجرته المجله فان حوالي 67%
من الجمهوريين يفضلون ترشيحه ترامب على
تصدر العناوين في الاونه الاخيره بعد
ملاحقته قضائيا في الكثير من القضايا
ملاحقات قضائيه حولها ترامب لصالحه من
خلال كسب تعاطف الكثيرين تقول المجلات كما
ان الازمات الاقتصاديه الاخيره قد تصب
لصالح ترامب فالكثير من النخيبين باتوا
يفضلون التصويت لمرشح لالمام بعالم المال
والاعمال لايجاد حل لازمتهما ولا شك ان
نجاحه ترامب كرجل اعمال قد يجعل منه في
اعينه الكثيرين المنقذ الذي طال انتظاره
وسام الذهبي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات